[Music]
is giving us
all the feels in his new music video and
we're all crying
it's just extremely unexpected on
thursday the 22 year old rapper dropped
the music video for his new song
sun goes down where he looks back at his
younger self and reflects on how he felt
about his sexuality growing up
these gay thoughts on me i pray
god will take it from me it's hard for
you when you're fighting the video takes
another unexpected turn
giving us this emotional moment of a
younger little nas attending his high
school prom
heartbreaking moments aside there's also
some fun flashbacks of the rapper
paying homage to his early nicki minaj
stan twitter account days
[Music]
the rapper has never been shy about his
love for nikki he even dressed up in
this halloween costume last year oh my
god
and although sun goes down may reflect
on how he felt about himself in the past
lone loss is all about embracing his
authentic self in may he told
entertainment weekly quote i feel like
it's very important especially in this
age to forgive yourself for the past
at the end of the day you're the main
person that has to depend on you before
anybody else
i'm keeping the energy positive low nos
has been keeping that energy consistent
all year in march he released his
long-awaited single
call me by your name and the
controversial music video where he's
seen sliding down a pole heading to the
gates of hell
to give the devil a lap dance
[Music]
and we can only wonder if he's planning
on making the same entrance on saturday
as he's set to perform on saturday night
live hi i'm annie taylor joy and i'm
hosting the season finale of snl this
week with musical guest little nazix
it's the last show of the season y'all
say the best for last well we want to be
humble the other shades were great too
no this is the best one performing on
snl marks the rapper's latest career
milestone when he spoke to et in 2019
he opened up about embracing these
monumental moments
i guess i'm like in a in a constant
state of you know realization and like
just like life in general and how
everything is happening for me and just
and then
you know just grateful overall yeah